so often in life when we think about
change we're constantly fixated on the
outcome be incremental and make those
incremental goals important enough to
give yourself some sense of satisfaction
[Music]
greetings earthlings welcome to the
podcast so it's been a minute but today
I am delighted to welcome the return of
my friend Guru Singh longtime listeners
viewers remember well this Mystic Master
spiritual teacher I'm a constant student
as well as a constant teacher a dear
friend who has dropped many a wisdom
Pearl with all of you guys over the
years he's back today to Muse on the
subject of growth and transformation and
the delicate balance between doing and
being my purpose on Earth is to do X
my purpose on Earth is to do X
X that's it that's it we also explore
the Essential Elements of lasting change
how to cultivate the inner awareness and
strength needed to create a positive
impact in our lives and the world around
us as well as many other topics so let's
spin the mandala and enjoy
well it's so good to see you I can't
even remember the last time you were
here but it was a while ago so we're
here to reprise pick up on uh where we
last left off and see where it goes yeah
that we always punch pause we never
punch end yeah there's no end there's
just there's just pause there's
something there's something uh profound
in that statement I think if you
extrapolate on that idea
are there any stops or only pauses
there are stops that last longer than
others but then they have a LinkedIn
startup so it's a it's a pause with a
long stop what we end up with oftentimes
in our world is
sometimes those pauses need to be
good stops
in order for us to you know make change
or
rearrange right
extended pauses yeah that we tell our
brain
I've stopped I was just speaking to
someone just turned he just turned 62.
super successful uh he says
I'm unemployed
he had his own companies he sold them
all he said I'm taking a year off I'd
call that a stop that's a pause yeah
guys like that always find their way
back yeah you know
but the pause is the reboot to perhaps
do the deep thinking about what the best
next thing is yeah because every
everyone
in your audience has a driving force
and sometimes a good pause a good stop
gets you back in touch with that driving
force because the driving force when
it's activated has you in to act react
mode
but when you actually get to settle back
down into the actual driving force
that's when you start to feel like oh
this is what I was this is why I started
what I'm doing or this is why I'm doing
what I'm doing yeah it's hard to tap
into that when you're just going going
and on the treadmill of whatever it is
that you do like in order to do that
kind of deep reflection you do need to
take these refractory periods I mean I
think you know like a couple years ago I
started taking a month off every year
and those
those moments of repose have been
profound and not just helping me uh you
know make sense of what it is that I
want to do and prioritize projects Etc
but you know kind of below that surface
to really spend some time to think about
like how I want to expend my energies
what my value set is which values
require which energies when Etc
and and learning you know through that
process to say no to when to say no and
when to say yes you know which you know
Downstream
that has like real world you know major
consequences on you know the things that
I do and how I kind of tread the world
and that's a privileged thing to be able
to do I recognize that but it has been
incredibly beneficial and that's what we
need to work on as communities and as
cultures and as civilizations and as
Nations Etc
is that we have to be able to work on
achieving that collectively
creating opportunities for more than
just the select few
to have that ability I mean look at
Europe
Europe pretty much guarantees a month
off every year
in their work cycle
and so those are the kinds of
opportunities that give people the
ability to deep think to do the Deep
dive
and to have that reflective or
refractive period that you've talked
about
and be able to get back in touch with
themselves
and with that
there's a greater amount of Joy there's
a greater amount of Happiness there's a
greater amount of friendliness
and when we have that
then we're not running like we're
running right now in the world whereby
we've got Wars and disputes and
skirmishes and I mean territorial
disputes are crazy to be having in the
21st century there doesn't seem to be an
end in sight to that kind of thing I
mean I you know and and when I reflect
on you know Western Society certainly uh
it doesn't reflect that value set of of
the European nations who value you know
that kind of time off sort of situation
we're in a culture in which a minute off
and
uh you know a you know a second of of
lack of productivity is translated into
uh you know a sense of unworthiness in
the world which is a a very pernicious
kind of uh sensibility that that
pervades our culture and
you know although
it is perhaps Beyond reach for most
people to be able to take a month off uh
I do think you know that's sort of the
macro version of this but there are
micro versions of it I mean I know that
we've talked in the past about the
difference between reacting and
responding right even to take a minute
to be able to uh step back from a
particular situation or a decision that
has to be made to at least reflect
momentarily upon it so that you can
respond from a deeper value set or a
higher level of Consciousness than to
just spontaneously react and recur a
pattern that you've been doing your
whole life that you know always you know
ends up with you in a certain place that
you're trying to avoid
I have two things that come up when you
are saying that one is that in order for
us to shift the globe
Buffy Saint Marie back in the 1960s
wrote a song called the universal
Soldier
and she was basically saying it's up to
the conscripts to end Wars and
skirmishes
if no one
was willing to fight
then those that are producing the ideas
of War Skirmish territorial disputes Etc
would have nobody to operate their
operation
and the second thing is the idea of no
one has the opportunity or not as many
people have the opportunity to take a
month off
how about
what you and I were discussing earlier
and that is to take
15 to 20 minutes off each day
and have a safe space that you go into a
safe space both physically in the
external and psycho emotionally in the
internal and go into that safe space and
get acquainted again right hi how am I
doing how how am I who am I why am I and
when should I be and what should I be
when and start to answer those really
personal questions having a daily
practice is the key to micro changing so
if somebody's new to that idea and
they're hearing you and they think well
I can maybe carve out 15 minutes
but I don't know how to uh you know
deploy that effectively like I can ask
myself who I am I don't know that I'm
going to come to an answer to that
question in 15 minutes but you know what
is the practicality of that type of
practice for somebody who's who's you
know less than immersed in
the kind of ideas that
speak about the people that you're
talking about are the vast majority
that's the norm
the norm is not knowing what to do when
you're given the opportunity of 15 or 20
minutes right
because we've gone along for so many
centuries in this
get it up catch it up catch it up get it
up catch it up get it up
ever since we discovered the world was
round right we've been building more
merchandise than we can consume and
trying to Market it so that we have a
place for it to go
and that's just really crazy making
and so for centuries there's been no
real
moment to sit down in the field of your
crop you know and wait for the plants to
grow
you don't have anything to do at that
moment so you do what you do and that
was the old agrarian society
now what we have is we have the
opportunity and this is what I've been
working with we have the opportunity to
guide people and to provide for people
the ideas and the and the and the
mechanisms that they can insert into
their world on a daily basis
it's almost like the the old paint by
numbers to get an acquaintance with
colors and color sharing
so that then you can go on to paint by
your own numbers
and and start to express yourself on the
canvas of life
um so you're right
we could take that 15 or 20 minutes but
what do I do with it and so that's why
people like myself like you are
providing I mean take for example
what should I do with it let me listen
to a ritual podcast because I will get
some insight some inspiration from the
people that he has put together
that will be something applicable to my
own world
or let me do a guided meditation let me
let me do some breath work
let me take a walk
let me do these things that I can use to
get back in touch with me so that's what
I'm doing and that's what you're doing I
think in the in the sort of
self-improvement uh you know internet
ecosystem of podcasts and blogs and
social media accounts there's a lot of
content out there around certain daily
practices whether they're morning
routines or things that we should do
every day
and all of them
on in their own right are are cool
beneficial things like get in a cold
plunge take a cold shower take a you
know go on a daily walk uh morning Pages
daily journaling uh you know meditation
practice some mindfulness practice
here's some breath work exercises
um
but I also think that not that there's a
downside to any of these or a dark side
but I think when you're impulsed with so
many options it becomes paralyzing like
well I could do all of these things but
I don't have three hours for my morning
you know I can't do my coal plunge and
do my breath work and do my meditation
and do my journaling and then you know
have my artist date with myself and all
you know so so then people get stuck and
they don't do anything right like it's
it's about like finding one thing that
will work for you and then
developing a way to make that
sustainable in your life because it's
the it's the consistency or the
repetition of the individual thing it
almost doesn't matter which of these
modalities you opt for as long as you uh
you know kind of create a routine around
them that works within the construct of
your life so that you are actually doing
it well let's take an idea
everybody
eats some sort of a breakfast breakfast
means breaking the fast breaking the
fast of night
so some people say well I never eat
breakfast well they eat a first meal and
whether they eat it at 12 noon or two in
the afternoon that first meal is them
breaking their fast so it's a breakfast
what if we said
if you want to get in touch with you
get in touch with something that
everybody does
everybody choose their food
and what if you just became mindful
when you sat down
that you okay I'm chewing this food
and I'm swallowing this food so that I
can nourish myself
and that's all it took me 30 seconds
to a minute for that first bite
and that's the beginning point I'm
nourishing myself and in that moment
you've nourished yourself physically
and you've also nourished yourself
psycho emotionally
because you've put feeling into it
you've put thought into it and your
physical body is going to respond to it
and so my my statement is that two
people that don't know they're
overwhelmed they don't know what you
know which way to go how to start what
to do when they start
is let's just start at something that's
super common that's multitasking your
situation because you're going to eat
anyway right so how do you how do you
turn what you were going to do anyway
this ordinary act into a mindfulness
practice and you don't have to do it for
the whole meal because you might be with
other people and you're going to have to
talk during the meal so yeah you know or
say something or be somewhere but if you
just decided
that you are going to
take that first bite and just be
extremely mindful of that first bite
that's actually what was called Grace
you know okay let's all say grace you
know people say a prayer before their
meal
what's better than a prayer of
mindfulness in the beginning of a meal I
remember that Bertrand Russell had
something to say about uh the importance
of chewing your food and so I was trying
to look that up I can't find it right
now chew each mouthful 50 times is that
what he said yeah I just remembered
something in the back of my mind from a
long time ago and that's a lot yeah I
tried yeah I tried that twice that's
that's it's it's a lot you know it's a
lot more challenging I mean it took
forever to finish the meal so even if
you did that uh you would entertain your
your dining guests exactly we'll take it
down you know from 50 take it down to 10
or 15. re and it's surprising
what you get into you feel your teeth
you feel your tongue you all of a sudden
feel this thing it's it's not just this
you know stuffing it in and pushing it
down it's it's an amazing component of
Life the act of taking in food and
nourishment yeah which by the way
connects us to the gut brain
you know the medical Sciences
discovering the three brains and there's
a lot of Neurology in the heart and in
the gut
and the gut brain is all about
connection and nourishment
not just food
but also socially
that you and I are connecting and
nourishing each other and the people
that you connect with through the gut
brain are the ones that are really
impactful in your life the ones that you
really look forward to in life because
they are so nourishing just like the
food you take into the gut
affecting each other's microbes hmm
perfect
well the the kind of overarching
umbrella
um
for today's conversation at least in my
mind kind of what I wanted to explore
with you
um is is perhaps a little bit more uh
grounded in practicality than than some
of our past more esoteric and ephemeral
conversations uh
in my mind like I've been spending a lot
of time thinking about
change positive change
um I think if there's one kind of
overarching theme to this podcast it is
transformation like the power that we
all have to transform Our Lives to make
positive changes lasting positive
changes in our lives
um and I've hosted you know many
examples of these types of people and
I've experienced my own version of this
and and you know I believe deeply and
profoundly that that you know we all
have that latent capacity within us and
yet
for the most part you see so many people
struggling not to become enlightened or
or to become a meditation Master but
simply to improve their lives marginally
right like we're now in it's the
beginning of March we're past the sort
of New Year's resolution phase of people
testing out their resolutions trying
failing stumbling Etc so
that idea of like habit change and like
how do you level up or how do you
you know try to incorporate some
practices into your life that are going
to allow you to step into a more
self-actualized or or uh or or an
individual who is living their life with
more Fidelity to their their value set
like how do you become more idealized
not in the sense of you becoming some
kind of Supernatural human being but
just like you know living better than
you have been and I think that people
trip up they get discouraged
that leads to paralysis or a sense of
self-disappointment or or a sense of
lack of agency to make those kind of
changes in their lives and so I really
wanted to get your thoughts on how you
think about this kind of thing I'm sure
you come up against this with the people
that you work with and have probably
spent a lot of time thinking about this
yourself in the modern times
we have what is called GPS
I used it to find the studio
here today GPS requires two things
where are you
and where do you want to be
and then it takes you on the road
between the two which is it says best
way right not only is it talking about
the fastest way but it's talking about
the most ecological way now and all of
these things what is the best way
so often in life when we think about
change
we're constantly fixated
on the outcome we're constantly fixated
on the destination
if you were to drive under that
condition you'd probably get in an
accident because you're not paying
attention
to what they call the way of the way
which means that you have to be present
in each moment along the way trusting
that the destination
is ahead of you mm-hmm
and so
that's what we have to do each day but
set up
like once a month or once a quarter
the lofty goal
and then set up the routine
[Music]
that keeps you present
then create the map
between the two locations
and then give yourself enough time
to achieve an outcome for example
there was someone in my life
15 years ago that was extremely
difficult but very very close and they
weren't going to go out of my life
and it wasn't my wife
so I said if she listened to the podcast
it's not her and she's heard me tell
this story anyway and I gave myself a
30-year plan
that I was going to make this
relationship
an absolute
locked Embrace relationship in 30 years
I gave it enough time so that I wasn't
going to require to be able to see the
change every single day or every single
week month or year
we're 15 months into it I think I am
further along than I imagined in my
30-year projection but what gave me that
opportunity was I said I am going to
change this whether it's my change or
their change
to be an embracing relationship
in a period of time that gave it time to
make the shift
and so the first thing I would advise
people to do
is give yourself enough time so that
you're not working under the hammer of
urgency you use the word agency
the the thing that will displace agency
is urgency
because with urgency you can't get back
to self and if you don't get back to
that self-authorizing I have the right
to do this
then agency is out well a couple of
Reflections on that I mean in terms of
timelines I've often said that we should
be extending the timelines on the
changes that we're trying to manifest in
our lives I've said
that I think we over index on on what we
can do or achieve and you know short
periods of time or a year but really
under index or don't give enough weight
or thought or intention to longer time
periods what are you going to be doing
in a decade because our we're not wired
really to be able to cast our gaze that
far forward like it becomes very
difficult because what you have to do to
kind of extend your point
is Master small little tasks over time
that are nudging you in a New Direction
ever so slightly but in a way as I said
earlier that they are not disrupting
your life entirely because if they're
too disruptive they don't become
sustainable and you're set up to
ultimately abandon them right so it's
not about you have to you have to set
that goal you have to care about you
know that destination but you also have
to forget about that destination and
focus on like what your values are and
just changing your habits to be more in
alignment with that value set so that it
becomes an aspect simply of how you live
and that detaches you from that
destination because you're in that
process you are you are becoming that
person that you want to be and the
destination becomes less important I
like that
and it reminded me of something that
I've used over time Sunday worship
as opposed to Sunday worship Sunday
worship and I've done it for decades on
Sunday
usually in the afternoon
I'll write down the words that I want to
relate to that indicate something that I
want to be able to achieve in the larger
picture
in this week
and then when the next Sunday comes
along I look at those words
and I see okay how many of those did I
work with successfully
[Music]
and then I make a new list which will
include some of the old list going
forward this is what you use the word
incremental
if we can set up and a lot of people say
well I don't know what my goal is I
don't know what my purpose is I don't
know any of this stuff okay let's make
that our goal
let's make the goal of I'm going to move
through time covering my base
and I'm going to eventually within the
next one year two years three years
whatever the timeline you want to make
I'm going to know what is my purpose
and so there you go you have a goal your
goal is to find your purpose if you
already know what your purpose is then
your goal is to make some real movement
towards your purpose but let's say you
don't know what your purpose is and
you're going to make some movement
toward finding that purpose the
incremental steps are really important
and that means that if you can set up
something that says I want to make it
from here to here
and just in this week
come back the next Sunday
how far did you get maybe as you said
you overestimated the short term and
underestimated the long term
you will start to adjust
here is the presence
and the preference
and in between is the difference most
people are just Gaga over their
preference
not living in their presence and
consequently they're falling apart in
the difference
but what you described was how do you be
in your presence know what your
preference is and just make your way
through the difference remaining
in your presence
and how do you remain in your presence
we go back to what we started with
be conscious when you're eating
I am eating
doesn't have to be any more than that I
am nourishing my body doesn't have to be
anything
more than that be conscious when you're
talking to someone
I am talking to Martha doesn't have to
be anything more than that
Martha is talking to me
be conscious when you're having some
kind of a of a get-together a gathering
I am in this Gathering isn't this
Gathering interesting it doesn't have to
be anything more than that these are
really practical ways of being in what
we call you and I in this conversation
presence
and then give yourself the opportunity
when you're alone or in a in a small
like intimate setting with your you know
with your family or what have you where
you're starting to think about okay what
are my what's my plan what's my goal
what is our plan what is our goal
and then you can come back to that
presence and you make your way through
that difference because when people live
in the difference that's when they
become really scattered
really unhappy
really unfulfilled not nourished
and they're the easiest people to
enslave
by the powers of marketing and I'm not
trying to create a boogie man here or a
conspiracy I'm just talking about the
way
the way is in this world in other
words meaning that if you're living in
to use your terminal terminology the
difference you're somebody who who is
sort of disconnected from that higher
version of yourself you don't really
have a sense of where you want to go or
who you want to be you're sort of in
this Perpetual state of of
discontentment and and Detachment I I
know what that feels like hey you did as
a result you become you be you become
vulnerable to well if I I you see a
billboard and you're like well if I get
that thing then I'll feel better or if I
buy that or if I if I you know if I can
find this other person to like me or
whatever it is you're trying to fill
that hole or answer that that
existential question through means that
ultimately you know proved to be futile
and aren't moving you in the right
direction but you're grasping it you're
grasping at straws because you're not
you don't know any any other way you saw
me kind of anxious during the last 45
seconds because I thought about an
experience that you had that has really
stuck with me you went to Sweden
and you ran across islands and then swam
a channel between islands you did this
thing running and swimming right
that was living in the difference
when you're in the difference
it's like you're constantly living in
that high tension
survival orientation
even though you know you're not gonna
die in your commotion
you don't feel like you're living
and we need to come out of that so you
get out of the water and you sit on the
beach for a while and you let your shoes
dry out and you start to walk on the
path
this is
living in the presence rather than the
difference I'll tell you Extreme Sports
Extreme athletes
what gives them the greatest reward in
my estimation from where my view is
is how do you navigate the difference
how do you navigate the overwhelming
experience
in the difference
and so that should sort of cement the
idea of if you're not living in your
presence and you're always Gaga over
your preference you're not in your
preference because it's out there in
front of you so you're lost in this
difference in the in the crazy Raging
Waters of your difference
give yourself a break
start to bring yourself back home yeah I
would push back a little bit on on the
Sweden example or the endurance
sport example in that for example like
when I was doing that Sweden race I knew
I wasn't going to die there was an end
point there was a Finish Line yeah and I
as hard as it was I was pretty confident
that I was going to get there and the
way that you get there is being present
in the circumstances in which you find
yourself and knowing what the right next
thing to do is but there is a
directionality to it there's a linear
kind of progression there where you do
have comfort in knowing that you know
when the day ends I my head is going to
be on a pillow somewhere and this will
be complete right and in the broader
endurance sport context there is a sort
of structure that gets overlaid like you
sign up for a race and then you do a
training program and you prepare and
then you show up for the race and you
you know you compete in the race
um there's there's like you know it sits
within a certain kind of box yeah and I
think that that is distinct from the
experience of somebody who is living
their life feeling confused
disaffected not fulfilled
um unclear on you know whether it's
their purpose or something that is
getting them excited about where they're
headed or what they're doing when they
wake up in the morning and I think that
that is a
um you know to to sort of coin Thoreau
like the this this this mass of men who
are leading lives of quiet desperation
you know like not not they don't have
their North Star and they don't know
um you know how to change that situation
like that is an existential kind of
Crisis that I think befalls many a
person
um and there are many tools and things
to you know reflect upon that we were
talking about earlier to kind of
um get clarity on how to change those
circumstances but I think that that
makes it qualitatively different than
the kind of endurance sport example well
I'll do Aikido with your pushback and
I'll hey it's not push back it's energy
because it's not necessarily pushback
it's additional information because what
you brought up is extremely vital
the difference between my metaphor
and your pushback
was that in life there's no Finish Line
there's no resolve that at the end of
the day I'm going to have that pillow
because in the race of life
what's the end of the race so if you're
living in the difference day in and day
out
where's the end of the race that's what
to use your previous word the
incremental views are vital so
practicality
give yourself
incremental measurements
give yourself some form some tool that
you can use
that if I get to the edge of this island
by tonight
you know if we're going to continue the
metaphor of the Swedish race if I get to
this point by tonight I am going to give
myself rest because that's the
incremental achievement
that I need to achieve
my big goal I'm not going to think about
it my incremental goal I'm going to
focus on and so I think that
one of the things that
should come from this communication
today for people listening or watching
is
be incremental
and make those incremental goals
important enough to give yourself some
sense of satisfaction
in my experience those incremental
things that you make a decision to
incorporate into your lot into your life
also don't have to be Tethered to some
kind of Greater goal like there is
something to be said for doing them for
no other purpose than because they are
esteemable acts on behalf of the self so
if you find yourself confused or not
knowing where to turn to develop even a
limited mindfulness or meditation
practice or any other kind of creative
nourishing activity ultimately sets in
motion uh you know an energy field that
if committed to will lead to inevitably
lead to Opportunities or other doors
opening or insights that will allow you
to make pivots and other decisions that
you might not ordinarily yes and the way
it's rigged is you're not allowed to see
where that's going to go like I think
part of the paralysis is that we want to
know what the map looks like like you
you use the GPS example like we want be
able to put in the destination and see
the route and have it all planned out
here's the efficient way here's the
fastest way Etc okay now I know what I'm
doing and I can execute but in life
you only get to see like one step in
front of you yeah and you have to have
uh you have to have a certain level of
self-belief and Faith to take that first
step without knowing where the second
step is going to fall and it is only
through practice and repetition that you
can develop that faith that it will
guide you or lead you and that requires
enough self inquiry and
and internal work so that your gut brain
and your instincts can guide you
credibly because if you are so
disassociated or disconnected from
yourself and you don't know how to like
you know kind of connect with yourself
in an integrated way those impulses or
those instincts might lead you to some
bad decisions
you spoke about multitasking you have to
eat anyway if you're becoming mindful of
the chewing and the swallowing and all
of that when you're eating what about
the fact that you have to perhaps Drive
someplace anyway
put audible on your on your phone
and in order to see a little further
down the road than
you might see listen to people who have
written books
who have done things successfully start
listening to inspirational books
in the time that you have to do
something else so that you can start to
get ideas and pointers from people who
have already gone through what you are
going through and you will find and I'm
not talking obviously to you people find
I'm not alone in this and that's a very
important place to experience yourself
I'm not the only one that's feeling the
way I'm feeling
and the moment you start to feel
commonality
and companionship in the way that you
feel that there are other people that
are in the collective that are feeling
this way too
you start to feel a sense of assuredness
because other people who have felt the
very same way have made it through
and so I know that even though I can
only see as you said even though I can
only see this far forward I know that
there are people that felt the same way
that I'm feeling right now that saw even
further forward and that succeeded even
further forward and so the one of the
things that's missing in life right now
is community
and putting us all online and covet and
all that took place hasn't done anything
to increase the the sensation of
community so Community to use your word
is one of the valuables you use the word
of values and I say well that's very
closely associated with the idea of
what's most valuable to me
and one of the things that's most
valuable to me is to know that other
people have gone through what I'm going
through
and they've made it through
and here are a few pointers of how they
made it through while feeling exactly
how I'm feeling at this moment yeah
there's an interesting sort of paradox
or or dichotomy of the digital world in
which we find ourselves in that uh the
more we've become attached to our
screens and and kind of you know had the
experiences that we all had throughout
the pandemic we have found ourselves
detached from Community detached from
Neighbors detached from our analog
relationships and yet at the same time
it's never been easier to find your
community online I mean you went from
having this entire Studio where you
taught in analog form to many people and
I you know have attended that studio
many times to going completely digital
and online and cultivating community
that way so despite the fact that we are
in this weird place where we're not
interacting with people in human form as
much as we should be and as much as we
historically have
um the access that we have to not only
information but to those inspirational
voices or to the people with whom uh we
can look to as as Avatar mentors has
never been greater it's of course
incumbent upon the person to seek those
people out and to make that decision to
you know put on Audible or a podcast
when they're in the car as opposed to
the radio Etc so there's a
responsibility I think that comes with
that but if you can muster the the
courage or make the commitment to
yourself to to do that the level of
nourishment that you can find and
experience is is boundless and that's
like the amazing thing about the
internet like none of these things are
bad or good or black or white it's all
in our relationship to them and how we
decide to use them are we using them to
you know suck us dry and to exploit us
or are we using them as tools for
self-betterment or for creativity or for
connection and Community you use the
word responsibility
what in that word the ability to respond
right
what in that word
for most people
is because responsibility always felt
like burden
my responsibilities right how much am I
due to support right how can a person
look at responsibility
in a higher sense rather than feeling
like it's a burden well to reframe it as
opportunity perfect like this thing is
available to you yeah you just have to
reach out and grab it right yeah audible
costs a little bit of money but podcasts
are pretty free and there's an infinite
number of hours of people talking about
their life experiences and I can
guarantee that if you go down
you know into that exploration you're
going to find somebody some teacher some
personal life experience that you will
resonate with that you'll find helpful
as a lighthouse or guidepost along along
the way but yeah I mean it's really
about the connotation of responsibility
like responsibility doesn't have to be
seen as burdensome I think the blocks or
the barriers here are complicated in
that of course everybody wants to you
know be marginally better or you know if
I could just like Master this one habit
where would it lead me Etc
um and and the impediments to that that
most people face are not rudimentary
they're they're complex in that it has
to do with like the psychological
blueprint of this individual and their
past experiences and and uh you know the
nuances of past relationships that
they've had or or or possibly you know
traumas that they've experienced that
that
you know create a framework in which
this thing that might be really easy for
somebody else to do becomes almost
impossible for the other person to do
tools you and I said before we were
talking on camera that we wanted to give
practical tools
and I spoke about the gut brain
and what you're talking about is
actually in the heart brain and so a
really practical tool
intentional breathing
if you can just sit
for one minute
put your hands on the navel point
and inhale pushing the belly out
just pushing it out like you're being
funny
exhale drawing the belly back in
and just do this
breathing
through the nose inhale through the nose
or mouth exhale
and do it for one minute
what's going to happen is that over time
if you just do this for a minute a day
over time you're going to start to get
in touch with
all of these incredible centers you've
got the naval points you've got the
solar plexus and you've got the heart
and the heart is divided into three
layers medically
three layers the the bottom layer the
middle layer and the top layer and so
are the lungs
and these layers have different
functions
and the bottom layer
psychologists have understood
psychotherapists have understood that
the bottom layer of the heart is the
layer of the heart which sort of
produces the sensation of Hope
there's a whole thing called Heart Hope
right
the middle layer of the heart is what's
attached to will or willingness and
action that's what they say you know
when a person achieves something when
they put their heart into it
when you have action there's going to in
the law of motion
there's going to be reaction and then
you need the top layer of the heart
which is courage
the French word for heart is core right
so courage willingness and Hope
created actively by one minute of
intentional breathing engage that
and all of a sudden you're going to
start working with hmm
maybe I could do that that's that hope
right
changing as you said the connotation of
the word responsibility I'm going to
turn responsibility into the ability to
respond which gives me hope well now
I've got hope and the ability to respond
I'm willing to move forward oh as I've
moved forward people have said you know
you can't do that now I've got to engage
courage right so if I can start breaking
it down into its incremental pieces
I can start making those Tiny Steps
towards the big change
little tiny pieces at a time
you mentioned
purpose earlier and we were taught you
were talking about somebody who you know
perhaps doesn't know what their purpose
is and how to begin the process of kind
of going on the expedition to discover
what that might be and I thought I was
wondering whether you are of the opinion
that everybody has a singular purpose do
you think that we come into the world
and there is this purpose that that
we're on this quest to find and once we
find it it's our it's our kind of
um role to to you know Express that
purpose or further that purpose or are
there multiple purposes and it's about
living your life and finding the thing
that you connect with and and trying to
you know kind of further that like how
do you think about that
are we on a mystical path to like is
there a singular thing no for each
person no I look at it this way it's a
journey
you know there will be a purpose at some
point in your journey to find the next
gas station
right
but that's not layers of purpose exactly
and that's not the overall purpose your
overall purpose is you're driving from
here to there and before you get to or
find the next charging station if you're
going electric right
it's going to become a big purpose when
everybody does go electric is where is
the next charging station so the idea of
an overall what is my purpose
it's a good desire because all desires
drive us forward
but again I relate back to the
incrementals what is my purpose my
purpose today was to come here to be
with you
but one of the purposes was I'm going to
eat breakfast before that I was going to
do meditation and yoga so
looking at the overall purpose is a bit
grandiose and I think it's a bit of a
block creator
being more flexible with the idea of
purpose and let it be
kind of like a tennis match is my
overall purpose is I want to win this
match but if I'm thinking about that
while I'm trying to deal with the
oncoming ball I'm going to completely
blow it
so my purpose can be many as you said
multi-layered but what is my purpose
right here right now
my purpose in interview things such as
this
is not about what am I going to say
I like to get into really deeply
listening and then trust
that what I'm going to say is going to
be in some kind of a flow with what I'm
listening to and I use that as a
metaphor in life
when I am
going to you talked about what are those
what are those tiny changes that we can
do well what is the moment telling me
how can I move in this more what is it
they say you can't you can't turn the
direction of a car when it's standing
still
how can I just begin to move regardless
of the direction
so that I can be really in touch with
what's going on
and then I can begin to turn
my direction
and then as I'm turning my direction if
I'm still holding on to my you know that
preference
my goal my plan my purpose thing kind of
thing my purpose to find my purpose
I'm going to be led towards that so if I
was to say to you what is your purpose
you don't have a singular answer my
purpose on Earth is to do X my purpose
on Earth is to do X
because to do hacks that's it that's it
it is funny and to do it to the best of
my ability yes answered in in in uh in
perfectly cryptic uh language so yeah
there there is something really kind of
interesting like to pull on these
threads a little bit when you think
about
purpose in the macro sense to say this
is my purpose there is something kind of
egocentric and narcissistic about that
like I have divined my purpose and I am
here to do this one thing and this is
what I'm doing
and yet I suppose the counter argument
to that is people who do feel ha they
have a strong sense of of what that is
it becomes a guiding principle in how
they make decisions absolutely there's
certainly nothing wrong with that like I
think that's fantastic and that's what I
call the do X right so but I don't think
it's necessary that everybody has that I
find that the people that do have a
strong conviction around that tend to be
people who are like very goal-oriented
kind of spreadsheet type of people who
like to layer uh a structure upon their
life and that makes them feel productive
and guided and all of that and I say
that without judgment I I'm not one of
those people but like I know plenty of
people like that and that works for them
that works for them but I think the
bigger thread to pull here
is this tension again a paradox like a
tension between
a kind of Eastern approach to an Eastern
application to how we live our lives on
a daily basis and and the kind of
Western approach so to say I have a
purpose or these are the principles and
this is what's guiding my decisions and
this is how I wake up in the morning and
and decide upon you know what I'm going
to say yes to and what I'm going to say
no to there's a sort of Western
sensibility to that it's very it's very
kind of tangible goal-oriented
three-dimensional
Etc versus
the more Eastern approach which
recognizes purpose as something
important as a guiding principle but
also prioritizes the importance of being
present like you're in the micro sense
of what is my purpose like I'm here to
like listen I'm here to be present it is
only in presence that I can find truth
or impart the best of what I have to
offer like how do we balance these two
energies of being goal driven and
practical and and you know write down
what you want to do and how are you
structuring your time and Etc versus the
Bertrand Russell like chew your you know
each bite of food 50 times and can you
just enter you know a social situation
and and pay attention these are forces
that are in opposition and yet also I
think
success or fulfillment or the things
that we're seeking come through finding
a way to alchemize these two energies
balance them and kind of walk a Razor's
Edge and how you're in relationship with
these two things you said
how can we
alchemize these these forces
my overriding purpose
is to wake up
is to wake up so it's not X it is X I'll
get back to it
I love it just as an uh just as a
humorous aside
my Chinese zodiac is the rooster right
the rooster is what wakes the farmer up
in the morning right then how come your
house and your studio has everything's
adorned with frogs instead of roosters
because frogs represent because my eyes
my big eyes I was called Hey froggy and
as I was a young kid and so froggy
turned into frogs and I've got hundreds
of frogs everywhere
so as a rooster my whole thing is to
wake myself up because I know that if I
wake myself up I'm going to have the
best opportunity of whatever I'm trying
to do in every moment
then by example my purpose is to wake
others up not
wake them up so they can do this or wake
them up so they can do that wake them up
so they can do whatever they want to do
but the more awake they are the better
they'll do it and so my overriding
purpose
is to wake up
my incremental purpose is to do X
in an awakened state
and when I say an awakened State an
aware state
a conscious state
a parasympathetic if you want to use the
nervous system state which is the system
that takes the step back and looks at
the whole picture before they make the
move in the smaller picture
and so
I look at it
okay I'm awake if I'm playing music I'm
awake in the music and if I'm awake and
the music
then I'm feeling the moment
and I can respond to that sensation
if I'm an artist same thing if I'm a
writer same thing if I'm working with
children same thing if I'm awake in the
moment I'm going to be listening to what
is it exactly
that I'm needing to fulfill this
sensation of angst
confusion or whatever the feeling might
be that doesn't feel good
there's a message in it if I'm awake
I can hear that message now I'm down
into the you know the quantum structure
of my of my messaging and I'm able to
respond I'm responsible and that makes
me able to then turn in a direction that
I need to turn so that the next moment
is a little better than the last the
next day a little better than the
previous and I'm starting to grow and to
shift and to change
incrementally so perhaps a way to drill
down on the essence of what you just had
to say is in the tension between doing
and being you can't properly do unless
you're being
and wow that's that's a quotable yeah
and in order uh to know what to do you
have to be
but in order to
be you have to do something
right yeah yeah that's the whole circle
isn't it
that's the yin and the Young
that's the conversation that if we just
came in here and this is what I'm going
to do to use your metaphor from the
previous point
I'm just gonna do this is a conversation
this is the way we're going to have it
we're going to run through these points
and this is the outcome that's the doing
but the being is
what the heck is grossing going to say
right in the middle of the conversation
what if he throws me a curveball
it's a dance it is right
uh and it's one that you I think can
spend your life trying to master but I
think it is you know finding that
balance between those two things and I
think once it tips too much in one or
the other directions then
it can lead you astray yeah and and look
really
positively at the concept of a pendulum
you know life is at pendulum
you know it's going to swing every once
in a while it's going to be out there in
the in the weeds it's going to be coming
back we're talking about the context of
of change within oneself like how do we
accomplish that how do we be what do we
do how do we instill greater
self-efficacy agency
self-esteem how do we get on a more
appropriate trajectory to guide us
towards the more fulfilling
purpose-driven life that's one thing on
the other hand we have this idea of of
instilling or or activating change in
another and and you know this is the
source of a tremendous amount of human
suffering right like the minute we start
to get involved or attached to trying to
get somebody else to change or to become
more like ourselves or to see the world
our way is the minute that we open
ourselves up up to you know unlimited
amounts of of like pain and toil and you
as a teacher you are a change agent you
are trying to activate positive change
in other people
how do you think about that relationship
and what do you say to the person who
comes to you who says you know my
partner or my child or my parent or my
best friend is you know doing this thing
and I'm trying to help them and they're
just not seeing it and if they could
only do this one thing like their
problem would be solved and I'm so
frustrated how do I get them to change
frustration in this particular context
will be felt when we're looking at their
condition
their position
their interpretation
through our eyes we have to get
ourselves into a position to be able to
see their projection their position
their condition their interpretation
through their eyes
that
can be achieved
over time and the one thing that you
want to stay clear from is frustration
because frustration will shut down that
observation
frustration is why aren't they changing
but what you're striving to achieve is
why
aren't they changing
there's a different why
the why aren't they changing is the
curious
actually wanting to know why
they're not changing rather than why as
a statement why aren't they changing
that's not curiosity that's accusation
and so if you can get into the curious
why you can get down in there with them
and literally in the course of the time
that you have available with them if you
get down in there with them you start
looking out through the same set of eyes
hearing through the same set of ears
experiencing through the same body
almost
that's connectivity
and in that connectivity which by the
way is a gut brain thing you feel it
through your you feel it through your
Naval point in that connectivity you
begin to share the experience that
they're having and they begin to talk to
you in a different way they almost begin
to talk to you like they're talking to
themselves
and once they start to talk to you like
they're talking to themselves you can
start talking back to you to them as if
you're talking from that same position
and all of a sudden because they're
listening to themself and it's you
talking they're starting to hear you
and the one thing that you have to
realize is that you can only take them a
tiny bit
in each moment because you take many
more than that they're going to go back
to the subconscious mind the
subconscious which is going to make them
revert back to my safety is in what I
was not in what I'm changing into
because what I'm changing into it's
completely unfamiliar to me and that
feels dangerous
but if you give them a sense of
camaraderie in other words you're two
people in the same body looking out
through the same Eyes Ears Etc
they feel like they've got a a team
to work with
family to work with
and they don't feel scared even though
it's unfamiliar yeah I mean what you're
talking about is dropping the Judgment
approaching this person from a place of
of of empathy you know with a capital E
like how can I truly understand this
person's lived experience so that I can
you know communicate with them in in on
an even playing field right and
acceptance where they feel safe
um which is you know an aspect of of
non-judgment
um and I understand all of that but I
think when you were talking about the
why like what is the why question
isn't the why question also like why do
I feel like I need to change this person
like why is it upsetting to me that
they're not changing or why is it
upsetting to me that they're who they
are and they're not doing things
differently or the way that I would like
them
to be right and is it even my business
to get involved with that if there's an
investment
if there's an investment it's your
business the investment is family yeah
the investment is
Associates
working relationships professional or
personal
the investment is a caring you use the
word empathy with a capital e
those are the investment factors so if
there is an investment
and in my sense there's always an
investment at some point in time because
we're all living on the same planet and
we all affect each other
that's the nature of the fact that we're
all sharing
this this planet I love George Carlin's
why were why was government created did
you ever hear that routine uh probably
about I said he said the reason that
government was created because someone
took a dump on the trail and somebody
came back into camp and said we gotta
make some rules around here and there
was you know how do we make how do we
make change
so that we don't need to live by rules
in those relationships in which we want
to have camaraderie rather than you know
rather than a set of rules that we all
have to follow we want to have that
natural camaraderie and that's the
investment that we need to honor and
like you were saying earlier if you come
in to try to control then the why isn't
so and so changing becomes a why of
frustration but if you think about the
idea of living in camaraderie living it
living in commonality then the why
becomes the curious why
the why becomes a how
how can we how can we change and maybe
it's not maybe we discover in in a
camaraderie part way through the change
process
that I thought I came here to change you
and actually what's happening is that
we're both changing to become a come to
become a common good yeah I mean quite
often the the chain like you can't
change another person you can change
yourself so if you're discontented with
a certain kind of social Dynamic you can
either you know Focus that attention on
trying to get the other person to change
or you can change your attitude or
relationship with the dynamic right like
that's the easier shift like what is it
about me that's so resistant or so
repelled by this maybe I can work on
myself to be more accepting
Etc more flexible what have you
um and and certainly there are
situations in which you know somebody is
doing something that requires a net or
some kind of intervention right some
kind of loving compassionate like hey we
need to kind of course correct where
this person's at maybe they can't see
what they're doing to themselves or in a
loving way like how can we come to this
person's aid but there are other
situations in which maybe it isn't
appropriate for you to intercede and and
I think in thinking about the nature of
change and how a person changes
lasting change only comes from a place
of willingness like like willingness
that that is that is percolating from
within it doesn't come from being
impulsed by an external Source or some
kind of pressure from another human
being that might create a short-term
change but there will will most likely
be a reversion back to the norm and it's
only when that person realizes that they
actually want to change or they have
that like willingness like uh you know a
sort of you know profound desire that
that is within themselves that that
change stands a chance of actually not
only transpiring but withstanding the
test of time
and I think that that is a factor that
comes into play in terms of how one
intercedes or gets involved with
somebody who that they who they think
you know they they're trying to help but
maybe you know if that person is on this
this is like a recovery thing but if
someone's on a downward slide but
they're not ready
maybe you got to let them hit you know
go a little bit deeper down until that
pain point is sufficient enough that it
creates a you know a receptivity to
doing something different when you
started in that in that thought
and you said maybe it's me that has to
change
oftentimes I have found over the Decades
of life
that once I start to make that change
that you described
the other one starts to make the change
too and we meet at some sort of elevated
paradoxical condition
that incorporates both of our
perhaps needs or wants and then that
makes it happen
further in what you were saying if
someone is not willing to change there
is a point where you say well I'm going
to put I'm going to assign a much longer
timeline on this one
and I'm not going to look for any
involvement or any
anything visible
at this moment not going to look for it
not going to look for it not going to be
frustrated by the frustrated by the fact
that it doesn't exist
at this moment and then there are also
those components that you described in
which we become harmonic
because
I'm not trying to change you
and you're not feeling that
and the willingness that you talked
about is that Central heart piece right
the hope and the will and the courage
and that willingness is okay
now we're starting to go in the fourth
dimension which is time right third
dimension of space fourth dimension of
time because that's the heart so all of
a sudden I'm willing
now the other person's willing
I'm hopeful
now the other person's home now our
timing and you said dance earlier
now our timing is starting to work
really well our dance is starting to
coordinate
everything is starting to work
now all we have to do is just
maintain the steps
maintain those incremental steps and
when we when we find someone who needs
that tolerance right maybe they have to
hit bottom you said
somebody that really needs an
intervention even in those instances
I've found that if I can find them in
the reflective Universe right if I can
find them
in a pixel of myself
the image that I have of myself one
little pixel has that person
dead to Center
so if I can get in touch with that tiny
piece of myself that's identical to that
crazy ass person with all of their you
know disarray
now I'm going to be able to as you know
the Buddha once said
the places I am to go I shall go the
people I am to meet I shall meet but the
most important part of that prayer was
the things I'm supposed to say will form
on my lips as I speak so if I can find
that commonality with that crazy ass
person that is being so outrageous or
being so destructive
now we can start to have a conversation
yeah in in you sharing that I was
thinking about
the fact that you know that the adage
that you know people just want to be
seen they want to be heard and most
people aren't you know so they go
through their lives and and they feel
unseen and they feel unheard and they
feel irrelevant or as if they don't have
anything valuable to contribute and that
over time of course that's going to lead
to a sense of of Despair and and perhaps
in the most extreme cases crazy making
right like how long can you go in your
life if you feel invisible in that way
big time
and you talked earlier about you know
there may be traumas and there be there
may be different things that have
occurred in a person's life that cause
them to feel hopeless that cause and to
feel unable to make change
what if
being seen and being heard
in a moment
could dissolve some of the traumatic
effects the traumatic After Effects
[Music]
psychologists therapists counselors have
found that that's the case
so often
that what you said was when you're heard
and when you're seen and it's true and
it's authentic
suddenly the things that have been
hassling you internally causing you to
act out causing you to be unwieldy
start to dissolve start to disappear
and all of a sudden that which was
traumatic
sort of comes down a few notches to
become just dramatic comes down a few
more notches it becomes manageable
now all of a sudden you've taken what
was trauma
and you've turned it into energy
that can be used yeah to transmute that
whole
Dynamic yeah yeah what do you think is
the thing that that most gets in
people's way when they're trying to
master some kind of change what is the
primary obstacle that trips people up
trying
trying to master some kind of change
the Mastery of change is available
always
that's the nature of infinity and I
always say this place has to be infinite
because
if there's an end what's on the other
side of the end right so the laws of
infinity are holographic
which means that everything is available
always
Einstein talked about the Continuum of
time that all time was in one moment our
sensory system just divides it up into
sequences
so that means that if I'm trying to
master something
I'm going the long way around but if I'm
accepting the fact that Mastery whether
I think I have it or not doesn't matter
but that Mastery of this whatever it is
exists
now we've taken a major step what
Einstein called warp speed
we've taken a major step
in bending time so that the distance
between
beginning and outcome has been
dramatically shortened if I just accept
that the success
the
outcome
the goal
is right here my pathway is much easier
so how would one practice that like in a
practical sense
like theoretically I'm trying to wrap my
head around affirmation yeah affirmation
I find that affirmations are like little
kids Jingles right
little kids sometimes tell themselves
something I'm going to be okay I'm gonna
be okay I'm gonna be okay and we don't
necessarily hear this because they're
doing it silently inside themselves to
themselves
but all little children have some kind
of an affirmative conversation
or the opposite the polarity to that be
depending upon how they're being raised
but if a small child is being raised in
the idea
that there are possibilities and
opportunities
then the little child is going to be
affirming to itself so think about that
in Practical terms as an adult
affirm to yourself
that the universe is infinite
and it can be taken care of
and if I can just allow myself to go
into that more relaxed State while still
remaining aware and alert
then I will be picking up on the guide
the indicators
they will show me I will see the sign on
the roadway that says going here turn
off there
I will hear the GPS system inside of
myself because I have the goal and I had
my starting point
so
you talked about you know faith and
trust earlier
if we would take faith and trust and put
them into more of a Consolidated
practical term rather than just this
elongated mystical term right you got to
have faith you know well what does that
mean right
well what it means is
you got to have faith that
if you're driving down this freeway and
off the freeway there's a ramp that is
going to get you to the place where
you're going if you keep looking up at
the signs eventually you will see the
sign that has the name
and you will drive off that's faith
faith based on
something that's practical something
that's doable
but how do I know there's going to be a
sign
that's there is a sign that's the that's
the there is well that's the faith piece
right like you have to believe
some kind of indication of where to go I
would say that that's the affirmative
piece give yourself the affirmation that
the sign is there the word confidence
means con means with and fidants means
Faith confidence means with faith so
give yourself the confidence
give yourself the affirmation the sign
is there and if the sign isn't there
I missed it hmm
but if the sign isn't there couldn't
that be an indication that maybe you're
you're you're on the wrong path or
you're chasing the wrong thing if
forgive yourself
like so how do you discern between the
two like you could you could talk
yourself into like this is where I'm
going and this is what I need to be
doing
and and and not and lack the
self-awareness to understand like dude
you're way off attack yeah you know what
I mean like and and maybe the universe
is trying to nudge you but you're like
no no no this is where I'm heading
the signs are gonna be there meanwhile
you're ignoring all the signs that are
kind of saying hey maybe like maybe like
do a little bit maybe not a U-turn but
like you know pivot and you get to a
place on that road that you realize that
you are way off way off course way off
base doing the wrong thing having the
wrong attitude all those things
humor and forgiveness are essential in
this process
have absolute confidence absolute
affirmation and then go for it and if
you're absolutely wrong dead wrong
humor wow I'll bet you there's been
nobody on Earth that's ever been that
wrong I bet you I could get the gold
medal for wrongness and then forgiveness
because forgiveness as we've said before
in previous podcasts is giving yourself
forward
giving yourself back forward so not
being stuck on some bad attitude or some
bad decision that you've made but giving
yourself forward to the present moment
and saying okay I'm going to go forward
with just as much confidence and just as
much affirmation and I'm gonna go down
this path dead wrong
humor forgiveness
and you're eventually going to get it
right you do need a healthy dose of of
humility like oh I would not mistake
absolute confidence for some kind of
calcified no arrogance or or certainty
because I think that that
to kind of get this right there's a
there's a there's a there's like a
surfing of the wave right like you're
kind of riding these subtle energies and
paying attention and allowing yourself
to be kind of guided here or there and
and not holding on too tightly like you
may say well I I this is where I think I
I want to be heading and this is I have
confidence that I want to achieve this
thing but there's a malleability like a
a kind of Detachment that you have to
have right like a non-attachment to the
ways in which you're kind of being
directed along the way I love that I
love that relation between you and I
because
you complete
and I complete
you're absolutely correct
absolute confidence needs
a big dose of humility
because humility with absolute
confidence steers clear of arrogance
which is the another word you used
and so absolute confidence with humility
with forgiveness
with humor
these are the components of the recipe
because we're not going to get it right
even with determination even with
certainty
we're not going to get it right
but to go forward if you're going to go
forward in your best capacity absolute
confidence is what gives you that
so you go forward with absolute
confidence and then the moment you
actually are registering this is way off
base
the humility to accept that the humor to
be okay with that and the Forgiveness to
correct that
those are the components that are
absolutely
essential and yeah absolute confidence
is very flexible
yeah that's a that's a complicated
recipe to stick in your air fryer and
get right I love it I usually the humor
piece like the the self-love piece
that's a difficult one for me like when
I
go astray
the the lack of of
self-love and forgiveness that I extend
to myself I think is a challenge for me
and probably for a lot of people
so I ask you then one question
do you want to start
intentionally inserting it fake it till
you make it
or do you want to
in continue to be in that
condition until the pain becomes
unbearable
so well that's my Mo yeah but I know but
what if
and that's not a bad Mo I mean you know
High pain tolerance you achieve a lot
but what if
you began to insert
into that equation I wonder what would
be
if I did it this way this time not that
I have to do it this way all the time
but I wonder what it would be
if because I just made such a wrong
decision and I just pulled such a
you know an upside Downer
wonder what it would be like if I didn't
feel bad right now if I didn't
you know flog myself right now
I wonder what it would be like and just
try it on occasion I think that uh that
com that that piece is common between us
um
harsh correction
can sometimes you know spill out onto
others as well right
and
what I learned
what I'm learning let me let me let me
do let me do a phrase correction
what I'm learning is
a little bit of maple syrup
in the chai tea rounds the edges of the
spices mm-hmm
and they're not so Tangy
and it's a more enjoyable
experience and the maple syrup is the is
the sweetener
and it's not I'm going to be drinking
honey
not ever going to go there right I'm
always going to have self-critical I'm
always going to be self-critical
because that's how I've learned to
maintain course
but I'm going to be I'm going to sweeten
it take the edge off yeah yeah well I'll
try that report back to you I love it
you know it's it's so cool because
you know I I you inspire me I inspire
you and
it's it's it's it's it's that it's that
dance well I always love our
conversations uh this one did not
disappoint uh maybe our best one yet I
thought it was brilliant uh I'd love to
have you take us out with a song but
before that
um
how's the Kundalini University going
you've got this whole online robust
community and I wanted to give you an
opportunity to share a little bit about
that before we end today's conversation
well there's several layers for people
that are just wanting to begin
we have these challenges we call them
it's a kind of a word that's used in the
in the online world
uh these 28-day challenges that are free
and we have lots of people you know a
couple thousand people joining
and they're real simple they take seven
to eight minutes a day
and that's in an organ a community
called the 13 moons
and so that's the sets that the doorway
in
and then for those that are more
advanced
we have Kundalini University which is a
globally certified 200 hour training
course
of learning Kundalini
kriya yoga
in a way that in my sense it's never
been taught before it's like taking the
traditions and then turning it into a
science which is always morphing
so that it's applicable to the 21st
century it's not like only ancient
teachings that are that are being
brought in but it's Ancient Ancient
teachings that are
being combined with modern terminologies
and Technologies and circumstances so
that people can navigate today's world
so those are kind of the layers it's all
accessible through gurusing.com
and the 13 moons is kind of an entry
point but it's also a point where
there's hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours of video
and in Kundalini University there's
800 pages of manuals and three or four
hundred hours of video so there's a lot
of materials that are available yeah
it's cool it's amazing what you've
accomplished in this pivot you know
since since the pandemic began and and
you let the studio go to move into this
digital space and and really create this
you know robust
curriculum and and resource that's
essentially an operating system for
living like in the way that we're seeing
the rebirth of of certain ancient
philosophies like stoicism being kind of
conveyed
for a modern audience as a practical you
know as a practical solution to how we
solve problems like there's this idea
that philosophy is just something that
lives in Dusty books and there's
professors at colleges who talk about it
but actually like this can be very
helpful in guiding our decisions to live
better lives and similarly you know
Kundalini Yoga is is a is a similar you
know strain of philosophy and
application for life that is Rife with
wisdom that is very practical for how
we're living in the Modern Age so and
that's really cool what you're doing I'm
gonna steal that because you just gave
me an idea Kos right Kundalini operating
system there you go okay
you could trademark that one on me on
you and that's the case because I always
get
very contrary to philosophy
I say we need to be practical
we can be philosophical
[Music]
20 but we have to be practical eighty
percent and I think the philosophy can
work like the sweetener you know it
can't overwhelm
but it can make it smoother but the
philosophy dictates the practical
application of a strain of thinking and
being right yeah
yeah cool man cool I think we did it
you're gonna play a song for us I am
good all right man grab that guitar
[Music]
so we were talking about um
the holographic and
confidence
[Music]
to be confident
that the infinite
will take care of it
we're so fortunate
to be confident
[Music]
made a long time
the long long time
sunshine
all around us all
Everlasting oceans of Love bring joy
Upon a Song
so we're confident
that the infinite
will take care of him
most all of it
were fortunate
we're fortunate
that's a long time
a long long time
sunshine
all upon us all
Everlasting oceans of Love bring joy
around us all
and the pure light on
live your Pure Line
deep inside
will be our guide
and then guide our way
our way on
[Music]
so that we can be
confidential
[Music]
that the infinite
will take care of it
[Music]
beautiful man
love you my friend love you until next
time until next time peace
peace
[Music]
vegetables and fruit
nuts and Grains